>>> WE'LL TALK TO CHEF JOSE
ANDRES AND HIS TEAM OF WORLD
CENTRAL KITCHEN A NUMBER OF
TIMES AND THEY HEADED TO IRPIN
AND BUCHA TO HELP FEED PEOPLE.
WE SHOT THE PHOTOS OF THOSE THEY
ENCOUNTERED.
THEY PROVIDED MORE THAN 13,000
POUNDS OF FOOD AND THEY'RE
PLANNING TO DO MORE RELIEF TO
MORE TOWNS AND VILLAGES AS THEY
BECOME LIBERATED.
JUST BEFORE AIR I SPOKE WITH
CHEF ANDRES ABOUT WHAT HE SAW
THERE.
>> JOSE, THANKS FOR JOINING US.
I KNOW YOU WERE DEEPLY AFFECTED
BIWA YOU SAW IN BUCHA AND IRPIN.
CAN YOU JUST TALK ABOUT WHAT IT
WAS LIKE THERE?
>> WELL, WHEN WE REALIZED THAT
OBVIOUSLY BUCHA WAS FREE AND WE
WERE LISTENING ABOUT ALL OF THE
NEEDS AND THE PLACE THERE WAS
FOR 30 DAYS TAKEN BY THE RUSSIAN
TROOPS, WE THOUGHT THAT WE HAD
TO BE THERE.
SO I WAS ABLE TO GO.
WE CROSSED OVER ONE OF THE
BRIDGES THAT WAS TOTALLY
DESTROYED.
WE WERE ABLE TO BRING WITH US
300 MEALS AND WE FOUND THE MAYOR
OF IRPIN RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE ROAD.
WHEN HE REALIZED WE WERE COMING
WITH FOOD AID HE'S THE ONE THAT
TOLD US IRPIN NEEDS HELP, BUT
I'M GOING TO TAKE YOU TO THIS
PLACE THAT NEEDS THE MOST CARE
AND THIS WAS BUCHA ITSELF.
SO WE WENT WITH HIM.
WHEN WE ARRIVED, ELDERLY PEOPLE,
WOMEN, SOME PREGNANT, A COUPLE
OF CHILDREN CAME UP AND WE WERE
ABLE TO USE -- GIVE THE FOOD
AWAY.
EVERYBODY WAS GIVING US SUCH A
BIG HUG.
SOMETIMES HUGS THAT WOULD GO FOR
A MINUTE OR LONGER AND THEY
WERE -- THE WOMEN WERE CRYING.
THE MEN WERE CRYING, AND
OBVIOUSLY THEY WERE DESCRIBING
AT TIMES THE HORRORS OF WHAT
THEY WENT THROUGH.
THE DAY AFTER -- SATURDAY I WAS
ABLE TO IN A MORE ORGANIZED WAY
TO DO A BIGGER CONVOY AND WE GOT
6,000 KILOS OF FOOD, 600 HOT
MEALS AND WE WERE ABLE AGAIN TO
GO TO THE SAME PLACE PLUS ALL OF
THE PLACES AROUND BUCHA AND
IRPIN AND SINCE THEN, EVERY DAY,
THE TEAMS OF WORLD CENTRAL
KITCHEN, WE WERE MOVING SLIGHTLY
NORTH AS YOU SEE MORE CITIES
WERE BEING LIBERATED BRINGING
AID.
TODAY WE WERE 30 MINUTES, 40
MINUTES NORTH OF BUCHA
DELIVERING FOOD TO NEW CITIES
AND VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
THERE RIGHT NOW UNTIL THE
MARKETS ARE OPEN AGAIN AND
THINGS GO BACK, WHATEVER THAT
MEANS BACK TO NORMAL.
>> IS THIS YOUR FIRST TIME
OPERATING IN AN ENVIRONMENT LIKE
THIS, IN A COUNTRY AT WAR?
>> YES.
TOTALLY -- WE'VE BEEN IN OTHER
SITUATIONS IN THE BORDER IN
VENEZUELA AND COLOMBIA, IN
HAITI, IN MOMENTS THAT I WOULD
SAY ROUGH, BUT IN A WAR
SITUATION LIKE THE ONE WE ARE
FACING, YES.
>> SEEING SOMETHING LIKE THIS
REALLY FOR THE FIRST TIME BEING
IN A SITUATION IN A COUNTRY AT
WAR FOR THE FIRST TIME I'M
WONDERING WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE BEEN IN
PLACES WHERE PEOPLE ARE IN GREAT
NEED WHERE LIVES HAVE BEEN UP
ENDED AND HOMES HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED AND YOU'RE IN BUCHA
WHERE PEOPLE'S BODIES WERE LEFT
IN THE STREETS AFTER BEING
SLAUGHTERED BY RUSSIAN FORCES.
>> OBVIOUSLY, THE HORRORS OF WAR
IS NOT ONLY THE MEN AND WOMEN
FIGHTING THE WARS THAT KNOW
ABOUT IT.
IT'S MORE THAN THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE IN A CITY WHERE
SOMETIMES BOMBS AND MISSILES ARE
COMING DOWN.
THE CEO OF WORLD CENTRAL KITCHEN
IS IN KHARKIV RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE CHEFS THAT ARE FEEDING
PEOPLE INE KHERSON.
WE HAVE CHEFS FEEDING PEOPLE TOO
DANGEROUS WHAT THEY ARE DOING
BECAUSE THEY'RE PUTTING LIVES AT
RISK AND WHAT YOU ARE REALIZING
IN WAR IS THAT LIFE GOES ON.
PEOPLE HAVE TO EAT.
PEOPLE HAVE TO SURVIVE AND
PEOPLE HAVE TO HOPE AND WHAT WE
SEE IS THESE FOOD FIGHTERS, MEN
AND WOMEN ACROSS MANY
RESTAURANTS.
I THINK WE HAVE RIGHT NOW I'M
READING BECAUSE THE NUMBERS KEEP
CHANGING, WE HAVE 260
RESTAUR
RESTAURANTS OR CATERING
COMPANIES, FOOD TRUCKS AND MEN
AND WOMEN THAT THEY ARE FIGHTING
THE WAR IN THE ONLY WAY THEY
KNOW WHICH IS WITH FOOD, MAKING
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE THAT NEED
IT WILL HAVE THAT PLATE OF FOOD.
THERE'S RISK INVOLVED AND WE ARE
VERY AWARE OF THAT.
GOING TO BUCHA MYSELF I REALIZE
THAT WE ARE MINES AND WE HAVE TO
BE CAREFUL.
WE HAVE TO BE COMING IN ANY
DIRECTION WE WANTED BECAUSE
THERE COULD BE A MINE WAITING
FOR OUR CARS.
THE DANGERS ARE OBVIOUS, BUT I
THINK IT IS MORE TO BRING THE
DANGER IF WE COULD RELIEF TO
PEOPLE THAT NEED IT THE MOST.
IT'S NOT JUST A PLATE OF FOOD
AND IT'S TO SEND THE MESSAGE
THAT WE ARE WITH YOU, THAT WE
ARE GOING TO CARE FOR YOU AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET YOU GO
ALONE IN THIS DARK HOUR.
FOR ME, BEING THERE, THE WORLD
CENTRAL KITCHEN TEAMS AND
VOLUNTEERS
VOLUNTEERS AND CHEFS ALL ACROSS
UKRAINE SENDS A VERY BIG
MESSAGE.
WE ARE WITH THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
AND WE ARE GOING TO BE W